[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
addie hour i'm honored to be able to
continue hosting these conversations and
glad that you all are here for episode
30 of this podcast it's hard for me to
believe that we're already on episode 30
we've had so many guests great guests
come through and that's definitely the
case today as well um i was saying
before we jump down that these are my
heroes in some sense i'm going to try
and hold back that i have a lot of
excitement just the opportunity to have
both of these individuals on the podcast
today and we're going to be talking
about faith community and mental health
partnerships so it's my absolute
pleasure to be able to welcome dr ayanna
jordan and dr sydney hankerson to the
addie hour podcast thanks so much to
both of you for being here
happy to be here when you call we answer
we're here for you
oh my goodness i appreciate that well
like i said these are my heroes in some
sense so i gotta go ahead and give them
a little bit introduction to introduce
you all as listeners to just the great
pioneering work that they've done i'm
going to go ahead and start with
dr jordan dr ayanna jordan is an
addiction psychiatrist and the barbara
wilson associate professor in of
psychiatry in the department of
psychiatry at the nyu grossman school of
medicine she is also the pillar lead for
the community engagement in the nyu
langhan institute of excellence and
health equity
dr jordan is someone who is dedicated to
creating spaces and opportunities for
more people of color specifically black
women in academia who are vastly
underrepresented
dr john is someone who has a lot of
accolades and has been involved in a lot
of different pioneering things over the
years i'm just going to highlight a few
of them one to mention that she was the
first black associate program director
for the yale university psychiatry
residency program when she was on
faculty at yale for quite a while
she recently also became the director of
equity diversity and inclusion for the
justice community opioid innovation
network she also serves as the medical
director for the recognizing and
eliminating disparities of an addiction
through culturally informed health care
or reach these are funded programs that
she has garnered so that's something
that we don't take for granted at all
she's also an nih-funded researcher
where she studies the long-term outcomes
for for providing addiction treatment
and face settings something that we're
going to dig into today as well
and just to wrap up and say she's
someone who's deeply grateful to be
taking care of the most historically
excluded patients during this time who
are facing extreme challenges in
obtaining addiction treatment even as we
continue to walk through the pandemic so
someone who again is a pioneer and i'm
just honored to be able to welcome her
to the program and to introduce you all
as listeners to the wonderful talented
inspiring
and wise doctor ayanna jordan
hey me listen have me back anytime i'm
like that was an amazing intro
i just want to walk away now but thank
you
thank you
brother so much love thank you thank you
definitely appreciate you
to also introduce dr cindy hankerson dr
hankerson is the director of mental
health equity research at mount sinai in
the institute for health equity research
he has someone who has also garnered
many different grants
he's been awarded grants from the
national institutes on mental health the
brain and behavior foundation and the
new york state office of mental health
he was formerly at columbia university
he had funding through there as well and
has also been involved in many funding
sources from private foundations
he's someone who's presented in lots of
different venues including the white
house including the united nations at
the national institute of mental health
also the substance abuse and mental
health services administration also at
gracie manchin also known as new york
city mayor's office
has just been involved in the community
in so many different ways over the years
he was also an inaugural member of the
american psychiatric association's
council of faith and community
partnership and have served on the apa
council of minority mental health
disparities he's someone who's just
deeply invested in the community and
also in integrating aspects of mental
health services and faith communities as
well and something that i know again
that's going to be just an important
part of today's conversation so again my
apologies for just being so overly
enthusiastic but these are people who
have just been pioneers in the field for
so many different
in so many ways over the years and
especially as black physicians i just
have to highlight the excellence with
which they're doing the work and the
role models that they are as well so
again you can tell i'm excited but i
just had to be able to give credit where
credit is due and grateful for both of
them to both of them for being here um
in this moment so thanks again
no thank you nee thank you for the for
the opportunity in the space of course
well as my listeners i think it's always
important for us just to be able to
check in with each other and see how we
all are doing so even as you all have
done so many important things that we
celebrate we also do know that the work
that you do is critically important and
we know there's a backdrop of just
challenges that we've been facing in the
society we're recording this at the end
of may we've you know continued to
experience so many different
shootings across this country in buffalo
in california
in texas at an elementary school and we
know that there are other things that
have been going on that aren't even
highlighted in the media and so we do
take time to pause you know to be able
to mourn to be able to reflect and then
also to call ourselves to action
but just in the context of all of that i
just wanted to check in with both of you
and just see how you all are doing at
this point in time especially with the
work that you're already doing within
mental health and thinking about how
we're processing this as a society
so i honor if we could start with you
that'd be wonderful
yeah i appreciate you really centering
um all that has happened
just in the past couple of weeks and
really being very um
deliberate and checking in because in so
many of the spaces that i have
been in i have been the one checking in
with others because
many people just want to go on with
business as usual and i'm like
pause literally like
pump the brakes
there are so much
trauma right now and i have never ever
think god really i'm very grateful as
by the grace of god i've never had a you
know serious mental illness that i've
had to really deal with but i can tell
you psychologically it has been
very difficult
for me to do my work because i
am
constantly thinking about
safety
what places are safe
um
you know as a woman as a black woman
oftentimes i think about safety in terms
of where do i park my car where do i
work where do i live
but
extending that now to babies
my nieces and my nephew
um
worshiping like what place is sacred
right and so
in a way that i didn't really understand
why it impacted me so much until i went
to my own therapist i think i'm in
therapy every tuesday at 11 i'm very
clear about that
because i realized that
there's just not a sense of safety right
and so i have to grapple with that
reality
and
um
it's just been really difficult and so i
really appreciate you checking in and i
this to me was actually restorative
because i said i know that i'm going to
be in a space
amongst people that i trust to really
talk through some of these key issues
because none of us are
um
protected against feeling the very real
pain of what is happening and so even if
we're not in it directly this whole idea
of vicarious trauma
is very real
um and so i've just given myself grace
i've canceled meetings i've said to my
team like listen
take time
and if you're not okay
i need you to be well because we can't
do the work of really trying to liberate
black folks
you know that's the point of jordan
wellness collaborative and really trying
to liberate people who have been
totally
desecrate it and just ignore from
society if you're not well
and um
yeah i'm just mourning and you know i
checked in with all of my loved ones
just to say i love you and just be very
honest about
the reality of where we are in this
country and so
yeah it's been tough it's been tough and
um i appreciate you for checking in of
course i think it's so important to have
that space and
i mean in many ways you've like you said
you're leading by example
because you're taking that time for
yourself and you're checking in with
those around you and i know just with
all those who are looking up to you i
mean i can speak from personal
experience and seeing trainees look up
to you see you take that time to pause
and that in a sense gives them
permission
to also have that time to pause to have
grace and so definitely appreciate the
ways you can change that even though
it's not easy in the ways that you lead
by example as well
yeah
yeah about you yeah i'll say for me it's
just been it's been emotionally
exhausting
um i think
the buffalo shooting is is especially
poignant um
to our
you know conversation tonight because so
many of the people that were killed
were leaders in their church
a deacon
mothers you know mothers of their
churches
uh
it was devastating
elderly black folks murdered in cold
blood while shopping
so i mean it just really
hit home for all of the church members
and community members that we work with
it made me think about my parents it
made me think about just
all of my mentors
and i think to ayanna's point um
i've had a range of emotions from rage
to
hatred
toward this um
18 year old who did this and then
published this manifesto
to
just profound sadness
to shock
to to you know you name it and i think
um
then tuesday happens right in texas
um and i think for me
i have never
[Music]
felt as worried for my kids as i did as
i was reading those
the articles about the story
um i remember like literally walking out
of my apartment it was my my wife was
bringing our kids home from school and i
was just feverishly trying to look for
them
and i know that was just out of just the
terror that something could happen to
them and so
it's just made me feel tremendously
vulnerable um
and also you know like ayanna i i see a
therapist
um i saw her today at nine so thursday
at nine is my session
um
and it's been amazing to process it with
her
um and also try to give the folks in the
community that we work with time to
process that because
it's uh it's been exhausting yeah
yeah it's so so uh so true and again
just appreciate your honesty because i
think in the same way
as a leader others can see that i can
hear that and that can validate those as
well and just you know the range of
emotions that come and as i often share
with people sometimes multiple emotions
at once and just
give me yourself time
to walk through that and just to be
honest about
the challenges that it poses for all of
us i don't know if there was another
point you wanted yeah i was just i was
listening to what sydney was saying
about and buffalo
you know so many of the
victims
being
involved in their church that being kind
of really an important
role in their lives and
last thursday so the thursday after the
shooting on the 19th i was at actually a
community event for kathy carroll who
was one of my mentors who
passed away suddenly
and we needed someone to pray to bless
raising money for a cathy carroll
memorial playground um so that the
babies have somewhere to play
and so we needed someone to bless the
space
so i'm like i know what all these people
out here we can find a praying somebody
a pastor a deacon somebody so i'm
walking around
to
um
elderly black folks and one of the guys
said i'm a pastor and i said thank you
pastor
can you
um you know bless the space
and before
he opened it up for prayer
i felt like very compelled to
obviously hold space for the victims of
buffalo
and he said to me i am so happy that you
did that
because my cousin was
murdered
he was one of the victims
wow and i have just been going and going
and dealing with
the
funeral plans and he's a pastor you know
and he's like this is the first time
that i've been able to like
just
take a breath and realize like this is
really real and he got so emotional i
got so emotional because here i am
i was in connecticut
you know i i wasn't even thinking that
like i would run into i was just holding
space because
i've somehow felt connected just for the
trauma of being black
and these people shopping
but then it became very real like
this is this man's cousin you know what
i mean like we are all interconnected
and so
that was really heavy man you know what
i mean like this is not um
something to do because it looks good or
sounds good like a check-in is real you
know
uh and i find myself
seeing that we as black people are often
checking in
and it's like do we do that because
we're mental health professionals we're
trained or do we do that because we
understand that we need to see one
another in a real way
and for me i think it's the latter
because i've been on many spaces
where i being the
the black person has had to sail
you know and so
i just think that speaks to a lot of
what hope we get into today is our our
collective resilience but also
when is it going to be our turn for
others to check in with us
yeah so well said when will others check
in on us yeah
you know
i mean to that question have you have
either of you seen a shift in that at
all does it still seem
like people are not
fully aware maybe it might not be the
best way to say but just curious if you
want to elaborate on on your experience
in that
realm as well
um i mean i i think that
it can be difficult
for
white people
to
bring up
issues they don't i think it's hard for
them
to
initiate some of my white friends have
said i don't i didn't know how to say i
wanted to say something i didn't know
how.
um
and then so there's that camp and then
there's also
some folks that
are just kind of oblivious
and just as to ayanna's point just kind
of going on business as usual so i think
i've seen kind of both
extremes
and i do think it's critical that
we do pause but we also
and you know give space to our white
colleagues to help them understand that
they need to be the ones that initiate
that instead of always being
black folks
yeah
yeah i think sydney's right on point
because
um so mondays i have um
lab meetings i try not to call my lab a
lab it's the jordan wellness
collaborative but for you all i call it
lab but we're in a community it's not a
lab because of sigma y'all got it but
mondays i have meetings with the team
and
this was
right after the shooting the monday
right after the shooting and
i was literally like i like was
literally sobbing i was literally
sobbing because just before
the meeting i saw all the pictures of
the victims and like sid said i was
sydney was saying i was like whoa
this could have been my mom my uncle
like i saw myself and so many of these
young people i mean these people but
then i started to think about the young
people because i read about an
eight-year-old that head
in the um
cooler
so that she wouldn't get shot
that's the same age as my niece
and so it i just began to sob as a
collective mourning because it's like
how much more can we take you already
shot up our churches
right you know
anywho so i was sobbing and
no people didn't know what's going on
and i took a breath and i said i'm going
to
we're not having this meeting clearly
i'm not in a place to have this meeting
but i am going to
have you all see the pictures because
this is someone's mother this is
someone's aunt brother sister etc
and a white woman that's a part of my
team
she said ayanna thank you so much for
doing this
because it didn't even hit me she's like
i heard about it
but she's like you know i live in a
suburb
around predominantly white people like i
read it and thought oh that said and
kept moving she said but not until you
show the pictures
said their names i said a little bit
about them like one you know was a
deacon and a just just affirm their
humanity
does she understand and she's like
i appreciate you doing this because that
helped me to have more empathy and to
pause
but see it's the thing is like why do we
have to show you that we matter
and the way that these
latin brothers and sisters were killed
in texas
i didn't have to like
like i was still affected by that
i don't know them right but see that's
my humanity because i know what it is
right but it's like i just am so torn
sidney because tiffany's right it's like
we have to
give our
white colleagues the space to get it but
then i'm like but you should get it
because these are people but then i
understand that this is a collective of
them not valuing our lives right that's
the that's the message
yeah
yeah and so important like you said to
bring that level of humanity
i mean also i mean i've just seen
unfortunately because of how things have
been going the last few years
people have even talked about the
opportunities for us to unite as people
but different even different communities
of color so as we had you know rabbi
buchdall on the podcast a couple or the
last episode talking about the hostage
situation that she helped navigate the
synagogue in texas and all the things
that she could relate to
on that front and then also the people
of color
in her jewish communities who are also
sharing about their experiences you know
from mixed families blacks who are also
jewish and the things that they have
felt which we can relate to as well or
when juju chang was talking about all
the anti-asian hate and how people
checked him with her but she hadn't
necessarily thought about checking in
with her afro-american colleagues same
type of thing but then there was so much
that she could relate to
so even in those circles but again it's
like you're saying even in those
communities people can relate to the
experience and they're having an easier
time i think seeing a joint humanity but
then when we you know when we're talking
about many of our white brothers and
sisters it's a different type of
engagement so i like you mentioned it's
necessary but it's also
challenging because you don't want to be
the one to have to bring that
all the time and so i think you know
it's just
something that's important to be able to
to hold that space and again just the
way that you have done that by example
and being able to pull people in but
then that can and that can be exhausting
of itself so it is
let me tell you something i tell my
mentees this and it's something that
like you know sometimes it's like you
got to practice what you preach and i
haven't done that but i've honestly
learned from sydney and i will shout him
out because one time i was i don't know
something and he's like i am not
available
i am my kids or and i was like listen
like that to me was so gangsta because
i'm like yes
he is protecting him
access to him and then i had to learn
why why am i not doing that because for
me it's like oh no i'm socialized to
for people always to have access to me
do this do that it's like no
you can protect your space so anyway i
tell my mentees
and i don't know where this came from
but rest
resist repeat
rest
resist repeat and i am at my resting so
on monday i was like i am out
don't call me don't text me don't email
me
because i
it's not getting
so i'm at a point where like even this
weekend like i love my family you know
black people we love our families for
the most part but i was like y'all can't
stress me i'm supposed to have the whole
gang here
for um
the long holiday weekend
and i was feeling just so emotionally
exhausted from everything that we're
talking about and i was like i love you
all but antaiana at the connecticut home
is not happening
you know because i'm in this phase of
rest
and i'm realizing that i have to do that
to protect my peace
for all the
addy listeners in the podcast you guys
are getting the
what's it called exclusive because i'm
talking to the um
yale residents for graduation and i was
thinking about what am i going to say to
them to try and inspire them during this
time and the message that came coming to
me was protect your peace
so that's i'm in a state of rest and i
will resist because i really do think
that my identity in itself is an act of
political warfare so i have to resist
but right now i'm in a period of rest
and sydney showed me how to do that and
model
and so i think that's important in terms
of the collective community you don't
even realize sometimes you're just
moving how do you move in a way and you
don't know that you have people looking
at you
yeah so it's like absolutely and so i'm
so grateful so then me you say ayanna
can you do the podcast yes now i don't
know when i'm gonna do it but you know
we're here i'm gonna do it because i
believe in you brother black man i was
so happy when i got to y'all i saw me i
was like who is this
fine man don't cuss me out to your wife
who is a
professor
at yale i mean i was so inspired i was a
resident i was so happy you were an
assistant professor
existing in that space and i was like oh
this is amazing so i think that
anyway it's just so important i'm so
happy because it's like
we have to
survive because sometimes we don't even
realize who is watching us who
we are impacting by just modeling that
and so i'm so grateful like i truly i
really mean this and i have to tell
cindy because i don't know if i already
told him like i reached out to him years
ago when i was trying to do my k for the
black church project to
have and i don't want to get emotional
but i was like trying to figure this out
because so many people kept saying
you can't do this you cannot provide
addiction treatment
i have reached out to a po and nih and
they just told me like
you can't do it
you know
and so i was just on the strength of
reaching out to him reading his papers
and the space i'm like
he modeled it in depression and like he
was so helpful
he would not only was he like absolutely
you can do this but he's like what do
you need you need my grant you need this
you need that it wasn't not like who are
you he didn't know me i was nobody like
no i got a little piece of the pie but
back
then you got a big piece of the pasta
it's so important so
it for me it comes full circle because
it's like
we have to we don't have to but i feel
i'll speak from a place of i i feel a
collective responsibility sometimes to
be there for
investigators
especially who are black
and in order to do that i am seeing more
and more i have to protect my peace
i have to have boundaries around me i
have to have team members
white people included that are going to
understand the importance of the work
that i'm going to have to model
sometimes empathy how to build that
empathy
[Music]
in order to be
whole i need to take care of myself so
that's why
i have i get on good vacations and i
treat myself well and when i live in
harlem my apartment is fly you know what
i mean because i have to
protect my peace yeah right yes
so well said i mean so many important
pieces there too and like i mean the
representation matters
even as you're trying to
get as you were trying to get into the
work and get into the space i mean i
actually wanted to lean into that a
little bit too because as you talked
about even the way you said you don't
talk about lab meeting in different
settings because that stigma still is
there especially when we think about in
our churches
so you know foreign says how did you all
actually
create that space because in a sense
you're leading by example
but you also bring all that
institutional
background with you for good or for bad
and so
how do you build that trust to even have
this kind of integrated
mental health
investment in faith communities to even
get that going because there's so many
that's been there's so many areas where
i feel like that could get easily
derailed
but you've both done that with
excellence so you i'm just if you can
share that you know with our listeners
as well
sure i'll go and then because i and then
i i think what ayanna did
is a hundred times more difficult than
what i did
just because of
because in in the black church at least
growing up in the south
there was more stigma i think around
substance use
and around like depression
and so that's why i say what you did
uh i think was in many respects more
challenging because of that
um
you know i i kind of came into this work
you know i i i grew up in the church you
know my dad's a deacon a shallow baptist
church new site my mama played the piano
from for the little kids choir that we
sang in
so i was at choir rehearsal on on
thursdays and in service on sundays
um
vacation bible school during the summer
some of my best friends
are from the church my college roommate
just my brother who went to hampton
um
that's right
so um
and then
so church provided a big part of of just
community it grounded me in my blackness
and it you know provided the foundation
of my of my spiritual life
and so um
i remember coming up to new york in 2009
for a research fellowship and knew that
i wanted to do something to
to help our people and i gave a talk at
greater allen amy cathedral in queens
about stigma and mental health
and it was really well received
and that kind of developed a partnership
with the minute health ministry leader
and we got a a small grant a narcissist
young investigator award and that was
kind of my entree into this space
um and so i think that
it really took just
you know we we're we're a communal
people right so it just took
being present
it took being vulnerable it took um
people had to know
that this was like my ministry and not
just my job mm-hmm
you know and i think
to ayanna's point about political
warfare i completely agree with that
um and we really frame this as an issue
of social justice
um in spiritual warfare and i think that
resonated with folks wow
wow um so that's kind of how we you know
started we did focus groups with pastors
then we did depression screening surveys
with the phq-9 then we created this
community health working training
program
recruiting folks from black churches
um and that led to you know our current
you know some of our current grants now
so it was really one church at a time
building those relationships going to
ministry meetings
um doing a lot of presentations
making a lot of referrals for people
because i think folks had to know that
you're there for more than just a grant
or paper because folks have died at a
helicopter research right
they tired of those coming in doing
something and then leaving and not
giving anything back
yeah i think that it really took that
that trust and being able to call out
institutionalized racism
calling out psychiatric misdiagnosis
among black men calling out
um
uh you know over criminalization of
black folks during the the cocaine
epidemic and then
you know with opioids so being able to
talk about all of those social cultural
and historical issues
um i think was critical yeah
i mean just just hearing you speak on it
sounds like you just brought your whole
self
into those situations you're honest
you're real about the institutional
challenges you're honest about the need
you you are building the trust
so i mean i would just get the sense
that people people knew where you were
coming from they knew as a place of
sincerity it was a place where you're
trying to to help and i imagine you
there probably still was some hesitation
in some places but it sounds like you
just you worked through that and you
addressed the big issues that had to be
addressed as well yeah and i think the
key thing is and ayanna does this too is
just the community-based participatory
approach right just having
folks from the community leading
community elevating community voices
um and and trusting them that they know
the answers and the solutions and just
trusting the process and being a vessel
to bring their vision to light so i
think that was just critical yeah
absolutely critical yeah i appreciate
you saying that i hope that resonates
with the listeners too just because
people who are trying to wrestle with
the best way to kind of approach these
things just as you mentioned elevate the
voices
right
yeah and i think i you know i
i appreciate the kind of arc that sydney
presented but i also want to just
not allow him to minimize
kind of the impact and of the space
right because it's really thinking about
like jay-z and the blueprint first of
all i love hip-hop so i always want to
think about how to bring in hip-hop
shout out to kendrick lamar's album is
so good right now but anyway
thinking about the blueprint because
sydney had already
for me anyway published in this area
when i had so many naysayers honestly
both from academia
right
nih
but and also people in the church black
people they were like you can't we ain't
talking about one pastor was like i
don't got no addicts in my church what
you trying to say i got addicts in my
church
and i was like first of all i don't use
that language but okay
but also i'm like just showing the stats
i'm like
people
who misuse substances are everywhere
yeah
and i'm not saying that this is just you
or a reflection of you pastoring or not
but i'm just anyway
but having to come in with
actual
data to say like look
here is a black man
who worked with black men
in the church
and
you know really
was able to address some of the things
that may not be as heavily stigmatized
as having a substance use disorder but
ain't nobody talking about depression
like that really just came within the
last decade really heavy in the last
five years
so sydney was doing this work before
then right
so having that like blueprint truly to
be able to say like look somebody has
already done it in this behavioral
health phase
space
we can use a lot of the work to already
show what is the most important being
able to partner with community to get
buy-in
similarly i was very comfortable in the
church because i was raised in a black
baptist church so i knew how to first
give it all
glory to god
you know so i i it was just like that is
who i am they saw
this is important but i'm not just here
to
you know
advance in my career and say deuces like
i literally
joined
varric even before
the pastor who is here now pastor still
like anyway i was there right when we
were looking for latinx churches to
think about how do we provide telehealth
medication for addiction treatment i
like went out to the church
figuring out like i know i can't be the
vessel i need to re really
work with my next brothers and sisters
who are actively using drugs and say can
you help me figure out like what are the
churches that are
cool
that you feel safe with because every
every church ain't a church that the
pastor is going gonna be okay with
having addicts i would never say that
but you know that's what people say come
into your church for care that's right
so really elevating those voices in the
community and they showing me and
putting
can we talk about this okay
me
these institutions don't want to pay
community partners
and so my thing is how can i use my now
i do have a little bit of power to save
to a place like nyu or say to a place to
you you got to pay people and not pay
them for no community advisory board pay
them so they can pay their bills that's
right because what cindy was saying now
we're thinking about social justice it's
not just a tool of accessing in my case
substance use treatment in the church
which has been revolutionary and i'm
super excited because we're showing that
people are showing up in the churches
more than they are traditional addiction
clinics and that's just facts
yeah
but also saying that for people who are
working as community invest
investigators i really think about them
as co-eys on the project how did then do
we set up a blueprint again
for economic security yeah so that
you're not just worried about
getting 500 for a community advisory
board but this is a role you have
expertise you can put it on your cv
trainings you can get so that you can
advance your own career so that you can
really support your family right so now
when people are thinking how do they
work with the durham wellness
collaborative for community programs and
faith-based settings i'm like how can i
hire you
through the institution so you can have
benefits yep
yep that's real that's real
right and so that's the conversation i'm
having now
and um
it's awesome it's awesome and i think
part of it is because i say like i can't
sing the lord knew that if he gave me a
singing voice i'd be out of control
shout out to my sister who has the most
amazing voice aisha i love you
and
what are my talents really i'm really
starting to see as i get older that my
talent is
bringing people along and shepherding
people to understand that
this work partnering with faith-based
communities and other
kind of community organizations
can be a way for restorative healing
that's transformative i mean everything
you just mentioned too
all the way across the board yeah and
both i mean just partnering and
elevating the voices making sure that
people's needs are being met i mean i
think that's just not the way
things have been thought about
yeah and what ayanna's talking about
ultimately is is you know transforming
generations right when you're when
you're getting
folks
jobs
at our academic medical centers and
getting them benefits often that comes
with educational benefits right you can
take a class you can do this your kids
can can have access or duke access to to
school
so i mean this is this is
generational change what ayanna is
talking about and i i think that is the
the great next frontier is not how can
we just elevate the voices of our
community members but how can we empower
them employ them
and then deploy them
and you know disseminate
folks out you know nationwide so
this is this is critical
okay wait a minute i heard a serious
word now
as a listener i
because i always will have a message in
a saying or something now i and i will
give you credit i'm not gonna be a
colonizer and just take it from my own
but sydney came with a serious word now
he said and how or how do we empower
people
employ them and then deploy them that's
awesome
i never even and i'm going to
to take it with your permission sydney
because how do you help that yeah
right that needs to be our motto in new
york city seriously ayanna i'm so
excited to work with you we are doing it
we gonna do the thing
you know we are going to do the thing so
i already want to work with them the
hope center at fcbc and they're going to
be right around the corner from you
hello i was like let me reach out to
cindy because i see he's already up in
this thing so i need an entry
absolutely absolutely
and
so we are actually going to be starting
um
psychiatry residents are going to be
there for a year
starting this fall from sinai
so i mean maybe say a little bit about
the hope center for people who don't
know
yeah so the hope center is a um
freestanding mental health clinic that
was birthed out of the vision of michael
walron pastor walrun from first
corinthian baptist church
it's been open since 2016.
it provides
10 sessions of
free evidence-based counseling
so the providers there provide you know
trauma-focused cbt
interpersonal psychotherapy
um you know problem-solving therapy
um and then they can connect people to
longer-term treatment who need it
but it's it's much more than just you
know providing direct care they also
have like wellness fairs they provide
space spaces for um
for yoga
for reiki for all different types of
healing circles
so they tap into you know the breath of
the diaspora and all that we provide in
terms of healing um and i just really
want to shout out pastor walgren
he is a brother who is just tremendously
transparent about his mental health
journey and the fact that he sees a
pastor
and i want to shout out dr lena green
who is the executive director of the
hope center
um she is amazing at program design and
implementation so
ayanna you were you were there yeah you
were there thank you because
it's just it's you are there
it's just so exciting i really think
it's god's plan for now sydney and i to
both be in the city both be in places
where we're able to
elevate this faith-based work because
i found out about fcbc because a good
girlfriend of mine who lives in harlem
was like ayanna
don't you do faith-based stuff she's a
adolescent medicine doc and she goes to
church there awesome
and she sent me their information
and i'm like this is awesome yeah and i
couldn't believe it and then i found out
that sydney was involved i'm like done
and done yeah i don't even know about
the psychiatry residents because i'm
thinking
can we
provide access to map because they're
right in harlem in a place that doesn't
have
equally accessible
medication for addiction treatment when
we know
black people especially
right have extreme rates of accidental
overdose from this crisis and we're
being totally left behind so anyway i
was like can we expand to have fcbc be
one of the sites where we provide
telehealth math
for free i would love for us to do that
absolutely so we i will definitely
connect you to dr green absolutely
making connections
together
and i mean yeah definitely pastor walrun
dr green for listeners if you haven't
check out episode 5 because both of them
were on that episode talking about the
hope center
all the work that they've done like you
mentioned pastor mike is just still
transparent about his story and his
journey with mental health and how
that's facilitates so many different
things in the congregation in the
community so
wow this is this is full circle and i
love i love making these connections now
you now you're going to get me sharing
stories too it's another episode of
episode 4
with dr alfie breeland noble and
doug middleton who's a nfl player that
was the first time they met they had a
great episode they just met in person
for the first time at an event suicide
prevention event so
see that was another full circle moment
you know just being able to introduce
the two of them the work that they're
doing the same space and just how much
respect they have for each other and i
mean for me it's just i'm getting off
top of here but it's encouraging to see
the way that people have been able to
come together on this podcast i mean you
know we're 30 episodes in that's
something like 60 different guests and
people working in different spaces
they're doing so much important work and
you know being in academic spaces
it's so easy for us to be in silos yeah
we do that really well
so as much as we can connect people keep
these conversations even the ways that
you all did that
organically and i would say divinely
orchestrated and the ways that you all
started i think is such an important
example
for all of us and i know i'm getting
even getting back to that you know
deployment aspect as people are going
out into the community or in the
community coming into these university
settings going back out into the
community and as much as we can continue
to foster
all that engagement and communication
i think it's just it's critical i don't
even know how to put it all into words
but i'm just kind of
yeah right along with the vision that
you all are casting if i can if i can
use that word yeah
yeah i mean i think you said it just
brilliantly and i think you know
in thinking about what it what is next
right and i and i think that sit i think
i know that sydney has already put it
out there with this empower employ and
deploy
because i think what really is next is
really thinking about
how to not only just elevate community
voices but put them in positions where
they're able to
to live right to eat yeah as the kids
say i don't know if the kids say that
anymore to eat to live to take care of
themselves i'm so old now i mean i think
i'm cool but then
my my nephew he's turning 12 at the end
of shout out to little lawrence i love
him
anyway i said something
i don't know i used some slaying i was
like oh this is so dope or something
like that he was like can you please not
say that like don't try
hold on try you're not cool
but the point is is really thinking
about how do we
go and underscore what cindy is saying
really think about
generations and legacy right that's the
whole point
and allowing people to
um
have a way towards advancing themselves
through this work
and
it's just restorative and so
i i'm just so grateful for you addie in
this in this podcast because i think
that you are bringing
people together like you said breaking
down those silos so that we're able to
move in a way
that um
allows us to to do this research
differently yeah
yeah
we weren't at this they weren't teaching
about this you know and my phd program
or in medical school
not at all yeah
you all are leading the way and i hope
that others are going to be able to um
continue to walk with you as you all are
elevating voices and bringing leaders i
mean it's the next generation of leaders
in a lot of ways too so
i know our time is coming to a close
that was way too fast but this i mean
this was a restorative conversation to
steal that word from the oil that just
again i mean i know about the work that
you're all doing but to hear you talk
about the journey into the work and then
just the encouragement and the vision of
things going forward it's just to me
it's so important in the midst of
everything we're continuing experience i
mean you all are
you are out doing the work and it's so
important and so needed so i'm grateful
to both of you i hope that the listeners
will you know get a chance to even
re-listen to this think about all the
different aspects of wisdom that you the
knowledge that you all have dropped and
just how important it is so
greatly appreciate both of you thank you
for taking the time to be here
especially with everything that you all
do with your schedules and with how
intentional you are about taking time to
rest too i don't take that for granted
incredible that you made the space to be
here so
definitely appreciate you both
love love love
thank you me of course
[Music]